the third dimension to travel you  welcome Ross the room you get in a car  you get in a plane yeah what does it  mean as your astral body as your soul  psychic stuff what does it mean to move  or shift well it's not the same time  space map you could have a lot of  overlapping energies between my hands  astrally there can be energies of fire  electricity magnetism earth there could  be dinosaur poop 65 million years ago in  the same space-time chunk right in this  little pocket and so when you do astral  travel astral projection you're taking  your awareness and you're moving it  elsewhere and so that elsewhere you have  two ways of looking at it you have the  astral and you have the physical and you  can unlock a lot of doors once you  realize stepping above the third  dimension you can access all of it in  all of time and space with the right  training and practice and validation  which is really key to show the  difference between a delusion and an  actual perception